[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce dernier
7,8 politique avant le premier tour du
scrutin des municipales ce dimanche 15
mars et je reçois pour commencer
catherine perrotin aux fastes et
bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes peut-être de l'histoire est en
vente on elancourt au tout début de la
campagne vous aviez souligné mener cette
liste plutôt sans étiquette qui s'est
constitué au fil des réunions publiques
votre désignation mamelles résultat
d'une désignation en interne mais
aujourd'hui en cette fin de campagne
vous réaffirmer cet ancrage plutôt à
gauche il ya un meeting qui est prévue
le 12 mars et le pcf europe ecologie les
verts ou encore génération seront
présents pourquoi tenir a affirmé ainsi
votre positionnement à gauche sur cette
fin de campagne
en fait nous avons pris une démarche
inverse de celle des autres listes c'est
à dire que moi j'ai été choisi par un
collectif d'élan courtois nous avons
construit ensemble notre programme et
c'est seulement ensuite que nous avons
demandé le soutien de l'ensemble des
partis de gauche et écologique et pierre
laurent mounir cette horrible non hamon
seront donc présents pour ce ce meeting
de fin de campagne le 12 mars c'est
important pour vous d'avoir ces
responsables politiques de présents
après c'est sûr parce que c'est un
ancien ministre un sénateur un député
européen
ça montre qu'on a de la crédibilité
qu'il croit en nous que nous sommes
compétents vous penser qu'encore
aujourd'hui ces étiquettes peuvent plus
tôt vous servir que vous desservir à moi
je pense parce que au moins nous sommes
transparents nous sommes clairs nous
n'avançons pas masqué comme certains qui
veulent cacher leur étiquette république
en marche par exemple parlons de votre
programme
en tout cas sur cette fin de campagne
vos priorités sur quoi vous allez mettre
l'accent sur fait derniers jours alors
moi je suis très très attachés en tant
que médecin à l'accès aux soins pour les
élans courtois nous allons proposer par
exemple une mutuelle de santé
la ville permettra à tous les ans le
courtois qui n'ont pas de mutuelle les
retraités les chômeurs
les étudiants les indépendants d'adhérer
à une mutuelle qui leur permettra un
panier de soins tout à fait intéressant
pour un tarif beaucoup moins élevé que
celui d'une mutuelle classique
je vais également m'employer à
développer une maison de santé sur
elancourt
vous savez que il va y avoir cinq
départs de médecins à elancourt dans les
cinq années qui viennent
que le maire actuel est en train de
faire partir le dernier médecin de la
clé de saint pierre en ayant porté
plainte contre lui au conseil de l'ordre
nous nous voulons développer une maison
de santé en offrant aux médecins des
conditions attractives pour venir s'y
installer
j'ai participé il ya quelques années
avec des collègues à la création de la
maison médicale de garde de montigny
donc je sais de quoi je parle j'ai une
compétence sur le sujet je suis maître
de stage universitaire je reçois donc
des étudiants à mon cabinet donc j'ai d
entrer à la fac et je sais comment
attirer des jeunes pour s'installer à
elancourt donc la médecine en priorité
le maire sortant vous avez visées en
évoquant ce recours se plaindre que vous
avez mentionné sur laquelle n'avons pas
eu d'information jusqu'à présent mais en
tout cas comme il n'est pas là je
précise juste que pour ce débat pour ce
pour ce débat qui n'en est pas un pour
ce plateau plutôt voilà éviter plutôt
les droits de réponses des uns et des
autres sinon nécessairement il reviendra
sur ce que vous venez de le dire et sa
forte pour l'ensemble des candidats qui
viennent en plateau en cette fin de deux
campagnes pour être très précis sachant
qu'il ya un conflit qui l'oppose le
maire sortant avec ce médecin on en a
déjà parlé sur ce plateau lors du débat
vous en avez parlé d'ailleurs vous
parlez de médecine je voudrais juste
quand même faire réagir sur ce sujet là
le coronavirus c'est ce qui inquiète le
plus en ce moment est-ce que vous pensez
que ça peut avoir une incidence sur le
scrutin
oui parce que ça peut effectivement
augmenter l'abstention donc moi je
conseille aux gens de venir de se laver
les mains avant de venir au bureau de
vote de se laver les mains après être
venu au bureau de vote de venir
uniquement s'ils n'ont pas de symptômes
sinon plutôt de faire une procuration
dans les jours précédents de rester à
distance d'un mètre d autres personnes
qui seront présentes dans le bureau de
vote est d'apporter leur propre style oh
si vous êtes élu votre première action
vous avez parlé de médecine
quelle sera votre première mesure ce
sera de modifier le quotient familial
nous avons rencontré énormément
d'elancourt toi qui nous ont remonté le
fait que le quotient familial à
elancourt est extrêmement injuste que
même des gens avec de petits revenus se
retrouve en six ou sept
donc nous nous allons utiliser une
nouvelle méthode de calcul du quotient
familial de telle sorte que nous le
rendrons plus progressif et plus juste
ce sera notre première mesure votre
première mesure en 2014 revient sur le
résultat le maire sortant a été réélu au
premier tour avec 60 % pourquoi des voix
exprimées pourquoi cette année ce serait
différent parce que je pense que nous
sommes allés davantage au contact des
élans courtois parce que nous avons
compris que les élans courtois pensait
que le maire était usée qui l'a 25 ans
de mandat derrière lui que ces
propositions ne sont en fait que des
propositions au niveau de l'agglo qu'il
n'a pas eu une gestion saine des
finances de la commune quand on voit par
exemple contrat piscine quand on voit le
projet de deux commissariats
d'agglomération qui va faire baisser à
nouveau le prix de l'immobilier sur
elancourt
quand on voit qu'il a dépensé un demi
million d'euros pour des cérémonies de
voeux en une mandature nous nous voulons
proposer aux gens une gestion plus saine
des finances de la commune
vous évoquez les chiffres forcément
toute transparence d'où viennent ces
chiffres du budget de la municipalité
que les choses soient bien claires oui
oui nous avions fait le budget est
accessible on parler de votre programme
juste pour pour conclure vous avez parlé
de l'élaboration de ce programme de
manière participative est ce qu il a
évolué il ya des choses qui sont qui ont
ressurgi ces derniers temps vous avez
évoqué le quotient familial c'est l'un
des points notamment
oui par exemple ainsi que les délais
d'inscription au centre de loisirs aux
cantines où les gens nous ont dit qu'ils
étaient vraiment extrêmement pénalisées
parce qu'ils sont obligés de s'inscrire
un mois à l'avancé on sait bien que
parfois les employeurs modifie les
plannings que c'est très compliqué et
donc les gens sont extrêmement
pénalisées doivent payer très cher s'ils
doivent s'inscrire au dos
au delà d'un mois merci catherine
perrotin refasse ted est repassé sur ce
plateau en cette fin de campagne avec
votre meeting qui aura lieu le 12 mars
les agendas des candidats sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet pour
la commune d'el en cours et pour
l'ensemble des communes de saint quentin
et quelques communes des yvelines
je rappelle que deux autres listes se
présentent sur cette commune
d'hallencourt celle de michel rossi et
du maire sortant jean michel fourgous
merci à vous nous partons à présent pour
mantes la jolie après le désistement de
dernière minute de la liste soutenue par
la république en marche sera falconnier
affrontera et l'élu communiste marc
jamais un candidat lutte ouvrière
thierry gonot le maire sortant de la
troisième commune d'eysines redoutent
une démobilisation de son électorat et
un désintérêt général pour le scrutin
le conseiller d'opposition municipale
communiste marie jamais élu depuis 2002
est devenue maintenant son principal
outsider il poursuit sa campagne il
n'entend pas la réorienter pour attirer
d'éventuels socialiste ou centristes en
l'écoutent
ça fait 25 ans que la droite et casse
cette solidarité entre les montées en
opposant les communautés aux autres et c
est comme ça tout vraiment et en soufre
que la composition de notre cuisine que
le maire dit qu'on ne l'a pas fait valve
montrer c'est à dire qu'on est même
liste black blanc beurre / montage lycée
la première fois je crois qu'on va la
voir et on prend du plaisir nous agirons
ensemble et on me se cogner ça génie à
dire que c'est la liste communisme je
suis communiste je me suis jamais cacher
derrière mon petit doigt
voilà pour cette commune de
mantes-la-jolie je reçois présents
patrick l'inter bonsoir cette tête de
liste plaisir notre ville notre avenir
il y avait quatre listes en 2014 sur
votre commune il y en a 5 cette année
avec les mêmes forces politiques mais
cette nouveauté divisions de la majorité
on a déjà parlé à quelques jours du
premier tour vous regretter cette
division d'avoir décidé de prendre le
large et vos distances avec joséphine
coleman ce berger maire sortante
oui c'est toujours un regret de devoir à
un moment donné se séparer et se dire
qu'on n'est plus d'accord sur les
priorités sur la manière de vivre cette
ville d'aimer cette ville est
effectivement de choisir des projets d
investissement d orientation pour
lesquels nous nous étions battus en 2014
qui n'ont pas donné des résultats
aujourd'hui sur lesquels nous nous
voulons continuer effectivement à uvrer
on sent des tensions sur cette fin de
campagne par avocats interposés
la fin de campagne est agitée
un petit peu là ça se calme on va dire
depuis quinze jours trois semaines y
compris depuis la lettre de notre avocat
puisque quand on franchit la zone grise
et que l'on utilise les moyens de la
ville des moyens aux bénéfices
électoraliste de la candidate sortante a
effectivement nous devons à ce moment-là
rappelés à l'ordre sur des choses qui ne
doivent pas être en place la neutralité
de la ville la neutralité des moyens de
la municipalité et qu'ils ne doivent pas
servir la maire sortante il vous évoquez
une publication sur le site interdit
cela est bien seul et sur lequel les uns
et les autres se sont exprimés sur vos
propositions sur cette fin de campagne
votre priorité
si vous vous êtes élu alors différentes
priorités mais une très importante qui
sera la santé l'accès aux soins l'accès
à la santé pour tous aujourd'hui à
chaque fois que nous faisons des
propositions sur la santé sur les bus
sur l'écomobilité sur l'environnement
elles sont systématiquement reprise par
la maire sortante qui nous dit je vais
vous remettre demain ce que je vous ai
enlevé hier
s'il vous plaît croyez nous ça ne sera
pas le cas nous avons travaillé depuis
de nombreux mois maintenant avec les
plaisirs oit pour train pour transcrire
tous ses besoins tout ses priorités sur
un programme sur lequel nous nous
engageons que nous saurons mettre en
oeuvre y compris pour le retour des
médecins dans la ville pour davantage de
bus et de navettes interquartiers pour
plus de justice et plus de sécurité
j'en profite juste peut-être pour
rebondir de la même façon nous avions
écrit ce petit courrier cette lettre
ouverte lundi matin aux services de la
ville pour dire à propos tient du coran
navires us il ya peut-être un certain
nombre de protections qu'il faudrait
mettre en place dans les bureaux de vote
et quelques heures plus tard peut-être
un manque d'anticipation peut-être
encore une fois une récupération de nos
propositions
la maire sortante à dire mais c'est bon
je vais faire ce qu'il faut c'est
quasiment un copié collé sur ce que nous
allons proposer
je formule le souhait surtout que ce
soit en place pour le bénéfice des
assesseurs des personnels et des
personnes qui viendront voter alors je
précise que toutes les municipalités ont
reçu des consignes aussi de la
préfecture sur les sur les choses à
mettre en place alors hasard ou non mais
j'imagine que les candidats font quand
même les mêmes propositions et et veut
respecter les mêmes consignes et
effectivement de vigilance et certaines
mesures vous le verrez et puis vous
très informé bien sûr sûr sûr le vote
donne avec des crayons qui ont été
achetés par exemple dé d1 des monts dire
gdg voilà avec des gels que woods ait
mis en place et elle serait encore le
tour des pharmacies encore aujourd'hui
lundi 7 manquants approvisionnements et
puis des rotations aussi voilà c'est là
où je voulais en venir pour les
électeurs avec un soin particulier
apporté à ne pas avoir trop d'affluence
dans des endroits confinés à certains
moments voilà absolument mais n'oubliez
pas d'aller voter malgré tout il ya
aussi possibilité de procurations vous
voilà je reviens sur vos propositions et
ce qui revient le plus souvent c'est
aussi construire l'écoutent la
démocratie participative commence à se
construire est complètement au travers
de conseils de quartier tout d'abord de
manière a effectivement donné le temps
donné le moyen donné le budget aussi
pour les habitants de venir se consacrer
à leur ville décidé avec nous les
priorités les investissements concernant
la voirie l'animation des quartiers la
sécurité et à oeuvrer ensemble au
bien-être au bien vivre ensemble au
travers également d'un conseil des
jeunes de moins de 18 ans qui
travailleront comme on le fait dans un
conseil municipal et auprès de qui
pareille nous attribuerons un budget et
enfin avec des applications pour
concerter pour interroger plus
régulièrement les plaisirs oit sur ce
qu'il pense des services de la qualité
de ce qui leur est fournie et ou tout
simplement faire des appels à projets
citoyens et ouvrir cette capacité à
décider la proposer ensemble pour
l'avenir de notre ville
un dernier point quand on reprend votre
programme vous vous engagez à 0%
d'augmentation des impôts
absolument c'est un engagement ferme
c'est possible nous avons dûment
planifié calculé simuler l'ensemble de
notre programme
ça passe complètement à la fois sur les
projets nouveaux que nous seront
autofinancés et également sur les
investissements courants qui sont là
aussi pour maintenir le patrimoine la
qualité de vie et l'ensemble je dirais
des bâtiments et des services de la
ville
donc oui c'est un engagement fort malgré
des dotations qui baisse de la part de
l'état malgré des dotations mais il ya
un certain nombre de possibilités
d'économies de recherche de subventions
notamment au niveau européen ce que nous
n'avons pas fait jusqu'à présent et nous
en avons toutes les compétences à
l'intérieur
je dirais de l'équipe avec des travail
beaucoup plus en profondeur beaucoup
plus en proximité avec les villes
voisines ou avec l'intercommunalité
et puis aussi en travaillant ensemble
nous l'avons fait en tout début de
mandat précédent travaillant avec les
agents avec les personnels de la ville
pour trouver des marges de manoeuvre
ensemble pour oeuvrer pour autofinancer
les investissements que nous souhaitons
au bénéfice de la transition écologique
la transition énergétique ou de
davantage de services à offrir dans les
écoles à la jeunesse ou à nos seniors
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau en
cette fin de campagne je rappelle aussi
qu'à un plaisir se présente djamel niati
divers gauche à noël prioux a signé
divers gauche également jean lui met les
pour le rassemblement national et la
maire sortante ait l'air joséphine
coleman ce verger fin du set 8 politique
c'est le dernier set 8 politique avant
le premier tour du scrutin le dimanche
15 mars rendez vous sur cette antenne
justement à partir de 19h30 pour
connaître les résultats des yvelines ce
sera également en simultané sur radio
sensations édition spéciale avec tous
les journalistes qui seront mobilisés
très belle soirée
[Musique]